[Música]
hay una realidad que no podemos tapar
todos nosotros somos parte de las
primeras generaciones en la historia del
planeta que podemos ver el planeta con
el nivel de detalle que lo vemos hoy
hace 50 años exactamente la tripulación
del apolo 8 estaba orbitando la luna que
estaban tomando fotos de los cráteres de
la luna y de pronto apareció el planeta
tierra asomándose por ahí por la luna y
uno de los astronautas decidió tomar una
foto con una cámara que tiene el color
esa foto fue la primera vez que se tomó
una foto de la tierra desde el espacio
y fue uno de los iconos para crear un
movimiento ambiental en el mundo mi
suegro es un austriaco alemán al que
nunca le vi soportar una lágrima pero
mejor que la primera vez que vio esta
foto la vio un postre gigante impresa en
la ciudad de berlín y que no pudo evitar
sino ponerse a llorar
algunos psicólogos que han trabajado con
astronautas dicen que esto se debe a un
fenómeno que se llama el efecto
perspectiva que le pasa bastantes
astronautas salen al espacio y sin
esperárselo a lo que ven y lo que le
genera más magia es voltear y ver la
tierra flotando en el medio del espacio
y ver la tierra como un puntito azul
pálido flotando en medio de inmensidad
hace que sientan que somos parte una
sociedad planetaria y que una de las
misiones más importantes es que tenemos
que proteger ese bar común
desde hace 50 años que toma esta foto la
ciencia y la tecnología han cambiado
muchísimo hoy día hay 2200 satélites que
están dando vuelta al espacio todos los
días y cada satélite o algunos de ellos
toman fotos de los bosques están viendo
temperaturas están viendo cómo están las
tormentas y luego y miles de personas
están en el mundo que están analizando
la situación de la vida en el planeta
y la conclusión general y 90 lenta de
eso es que vivimos en un planeta que
está en crisis y que además nuestros
estilos de vida son la principal causa
sus impactos
la paradoja de nuestros tiempos es que
nos hemos vuelto expertos obsesivamente
y compulsivamente en detallar y
registrar cómo estamos destruyendo el
planeta mente y vivimos como estamos
destruyendo los ecosistemas de los que
dependemos para sobrevivir pero no están
usando esa información y esa sentido de
urgencia para generar cambios de
comportamiento de manera masiva y hacer
cambios sistémicos para que dejemos de
ser una presencia humana destructiva en
el planeta y nos volvamos una presencia
regenerativa
no sé cuánto ustedes nacieron en lima y
crecieron en lima pero yo soy una
persona que nació en esa ciudad y creo
que todos sabemos que lima es una ciudad
fácil en promedio pasamos tres cuartas
partes de nuestras vidas en el tráfico
otra parte nuestras vidas tenemos que
estar ahí bien alertas porque no nos
roben en la ciudad hay que lidiar con
violencia con el ritmo se come riquísimo
también no pero la forma como cada uno
encuentra su balance el clima es
diferente para mí fue saliendo esta
parte naturaleza estos momentos estar en
las montañas con amigos acampando y en
nuestra el desierto o de repente en el
bosque en cualquier lo era en la selva
han sido para mí cómo poner un cable a
tierra son estos momentos que me dan
calma y me da la tranquilidad para poder
después realizar la ciudad y seguir
viviendo aquí con tranquilidad cada vez
hay más estudios científicos que nos
muestran lo que ya sabíamos que pasar
tiempo la naturaleza te reduce los
niveles de estrés y que además puede
aumentar nuestra bienestar y lo que han
descubierto recientemente es que no
solamente basta con tener los espacios
de naturaleza o el acceso sino que se
genera un cambio mucho mayor cuando
esos momentos con amigos porque como me
decía mi mamá los momentos sea el
momento de felicidad se amplifican
cuando la felicidad es compartida y es
que esos momentos que compartimos con
gente que hay esa interacción social
positiva son los que hacen que el
vínculo con naturaleza también se suelte
mucho mejor se fortalezca y el perú es
un país que es increíble para poder
viajar a explorar y tener aventuras está
la catarata de un día que ni siquiera
sabíamos que existía hace más de 10 años
la catarata de gocta y un día está la
tercera más grande del mundo y lo es
pero no sabía existíamos que existía esa
catarata hace menos 10 años
igual que esto tenemos complejos
arqueológicos que nunca han sido
estudiados tenemos 80 por ciento los
láseres tropicales estamos primeros en
los ranking de diversidad de mariposas
de orquídeas realista no para
pero lo que pasa también es que hay una
brecha entre lo que pasa en la ciudad y
lo que pasa en las zonas rurales
acá en lime abrimos el caño y no mucha
gente sabe de qué laguna o de que nevado
viene el agua que tomamos todos los días
si le preguntamos a cualquier persona
cuál es el nombre de los 51 pueblos
originarios que viven en la amazonía la
mayoría de personas tampoco te los
podrán decir y creo que todos tenemos un
rol para ayudar a cortar esa brecha
y hoy sí cuando tenía 20 años estudiar
derecho ambiental porque algo que
aprendí en los viajes es que también
naturaleza necesita algunos abogados que
la defiendan
y después estoy a derecho ambiental tuve
la suerte de entrar a trabajar en la
sociedad peruana de derecho ambiental
tiene un equipo de trabajo un equipo de
abogados cuyo rol principal su misión
era ayudar a personas que conservaban la
tierra en la costa en la sierra y la
selva del perú en estos tiempos conocí a
una persona que me inspiró mucho él es
víctor zambrano lo es también en la foto
victorio es una persona que es un
agricultor de madre de dios por 20 años
víctor sembró mil árboles y hizo que
este lugar que lo ven en la foto que es
un potrero es un bosque deforestado
convirtió ese lugar en un bosque lleno
de vida un bosque en el que ahora está
lleno de lujos de masas es de aves pero
no solo hizo eso
víctor además heredó le dio una herencia
este terreno schumacher enda para que
además lo siga conservando y ha
inspirado sus vecinos para que sus
vecinos también conserven los bosques
pero en el 2010 el oro subió a más de
1000 dólares la onza
y esos bosques que he visto la vida ha
reforestado y cuidado junto con más
personas estuvieron más amenazados que
nunca la práctica de la minería ilegal
en maría dios implica a dragar ríos
implica deforestar bosques hasta el
momento se han arrasado con más de 50
mil hectáreas de bosques predios y si no
fuese por personas como víctor y la
gente que los defendía hubieran sido
mucho más
el dato que a mí me marcó fue cuando me
enteré que el 60% del oro que se extrae
en el mundo es utilizado para ser
joyerías y me quedo super caro en ese
momento que si es que en las ciudades
seguimos comprando nidos de oro para
casarnos sin preguntar de dónde viene
ese oro la presión sobre los bosques iba
a llegar a los bosques más lejanos salud
que cambiemos las formas como consumimos
y producimos cosas en las ciudades ese
es un tema importante es que el partido
de la conservación que antes se jugaba
más en los desiertos en los bosques en
el mar en zonas alejadas
ahora también se tiene que jugar con la
misma importancia en las ciudades
ese año yo decía hacer una pausa y me
fui la tierra estoy una maestría en
cambridge en liderazgo para la
conservación y algo que aprendí en
inglaterra que me impactó fue que las
organizaciones de conservación allá
tenían miles de miembros mientras que en
perú somos un país megadiverso no habían
casi opciones para que una persona que
vive en la ciudad si pudiese involucrar
en la conservación así que en el 2012
realiza perú hablé con un grupo de
amigos y con el respaldo de la sociedad
para la derecho ambiental creamos con
cerramos por naturaleza y con sernatur
ese soporte una plataforma que el sueño
principal era involucrar a una comunidad
de personas que no se querían quedar de
brazos cruzados
era como juntábamos como hacíamos que
las personas querían hacer algo no se
sientan solos y puedan encontrar una
comunidad que los inspiraba y los invita
a involucrarse el tema clave de
conservamos es que hemos logrado crear
campañas que permiten que cualquier
persona se puede involucrar dependiendo
del perfil que tienda salud algunas
personas pueden ser voluntarios
ocasionales y otras personas dicen
cambiar por completo su vida
el inicio consagramos fue bastante
mágico el primer año fue como
enamorarnos de vuelta del perú pero a
través de los ojos de personas que lo
conservan porque comenzamos a viajar a
todas las áreas de conservación del perú
que vimos en un mapa y comenzamos a
visitarlos para aprender sus historias
tomar vídeos y hacer crónicas de ellos
para compartirlas con el mundo entero
pero las crónicas además le poníamos 40
de la lista necesidades que se
necesitaban para que sigan trabajando
para que gente que esté en la ciudad
sepa qué podían hacer para ayudarlo
hasta el momento hemos ayudado a que más
de 15 mil personas donde en alguna forma
de talentos recursos a la plataforma y
ayuden a gente a seguir conservando y no
sé si hay cuántas personas hay aquí que
han ayudado conservamos y se pueden
parar por favor
yo le quiero pedir que te aplaudan estas
personas ya las demás
y aprovecho y aprovecho para invitar a
las personas que no se han parado a que
ahora que nos conozcan puedan también
involucrarse en el futuro y les voy a
contar algunos ejemplos de personas con
las que hemos trabajado ellas la familia
es una familia rimarachín ellos cuidan
un bosque de niebla en las alturas de
bagua grande y si no fuese por el apoyo
de la comunidad conservamos no hubieran
logrado en cuatro años lograr las metas
que ellos habían planteado hacerlos para
el final de una vida
hace 20 años que no habían visto
regresar a sus bosques a los pasteles
del mono choro algo la maria animales de
esta especie y hace dos años finalmente
pudieron volver a encontrarnos en sus
bosques ellos son los colaboradores de
conservamos por naturaleza de loreto son
un grupo de jóvenes que son biólogos
ingenieros forestales y lo que ellos
hacen es como voluntarios ayuda a más
personas quieren hacer conservación en
sus tierras leonesas en los inventarios
biológicos para que puedan crear más
áreas de conservación y también están
liderando una campaña que se llama hazla
por tu río que es un hijito de una
campaña que los de contar después que se
llama hazla por tu playa que consiste en
limpiar la basura y los plásticos que
hay los ríos de la amazonía ella es de
una persona que conocimos recién hace
dos semanas que fue una charla hace poco
y nos dijo que es ella especialista en
marketing y nos dijo que después de la
charla decidió que nunca más iba a
trabajar para una empresa cuyo propósito
no compartida y también tenemos casos
como el de eduardo jackson que es un
empresario que trabajaba en y deme toda
su vida y después de ver los vídeos y
así decirte es inspirado de ver la
comunidad la gente estaba logrando vivir
más feliz con una vida más simple
conecta con naturaleza
comprarse un terreno bus a pampa donde
ahora crea un área de conservación
después estos años hemos creado un
modelo que creemos que puede ser útil
para cualquier persona que quiere
involucrar más personas en la
conservación y es un modelo que tiene
cinco metas la primera meta es que haya
más naturaleza conservada por ciudadanos
en el perú tenemos más de dos más de un
millón y medio de hectáreas conservadas
por ciudadanos pero creemos que podemos
involucrar a muchísimas personas más una
de las campañas que hemos hecho usando
la ley es una manera innovadora
esa es la portugal y ahora portugal a
consiste en proteger las olas del perú
hemos hemos creado un sistema legal que
es el primero en el mundo que permite
proteger las olas para que no sean
afectadas por muelles o que sean
afectadas por puertos y ahora tenemos
gracias al apoyo de más de 1500
tablistas 25 las protegidas por ley y
ahora queremos replicar este modelo para
hacerlo en otros lugares del mundo pero
también para poder proteger otros
lugares donde las personas practicamos
deportes y naturaleza como por ejemplo
los ríos ríos como el marañón que ahora
están en ammán bajo la amenaza de ser
represados pero que tienen un potencial
gigantesco
para poder ser la entrada ideal para
llegar aquí ya podías ser un destino
turístico esto nos lleva a nuestra
segunda meta que es que más personas
tengan un contacto significativo y
trascendente en naturaleza hoy día hay
estudios en eeuu que muestran que niños
de eeuu pasan menos tiempo al aire libre
que presos de una prisión de máxima
seguridad y este tema es crítico porque
es en esa temprana en donde generamos
los vínculos que son los vínculos que
perduran por toda una vida y que nos
hace más propensos a cuidar la
naturaleza hemos creado una guía de
viajes que se llama la ruta natural para
que cualquier persona ahora pueda viajar
por el perú pero de la mano de la gente
que conserva naturaleza como lo hicimos
nosotros al primer año que conservamos y
que nos permitió como rehén a morar nos
el perú ayudar y perú con otra
perspectiva y ahora estamos buscando
esta vía es completamente estos auto
sostenibles
estamos buscando replicar en otros
países
la tercera meta es que haya más
filantropía y que haya más incentivos
para conservar hoy día la mayor cantidad
de fondos que llegan al perú para la
gente que quiere hacer conservación son
de fundaciones eeuu y lo que nosotros
creemos es que deberían ser las empresas
peruanas y ciudadanos peruanos los que
asumimos la responsabilidad de cuidar
nuestro patrimonio así que hemos hecho
diferentes campañas que permiten que la
gente pueda donar recursos y talento una
de ellas es reforestamos por naturaleza
por 50 soles menos de 20 dólares donas
esa cantidad de plata y puedes adoptar
un árbol en un área de conservación y te
llega un certificado con las coordenadas
del árbol la spel nombre el nombre de la
especie y con las coordenadas puedes
eventualmente ir a visitarlo la mitad de
los fondos van al área de conservación
para que puedan mejorar sus proyectos de
conservación y la otra mitad es usada
para la campaña nosotros también damos
becas a jóvenes profesionales que son
los que nos ayudan a monitorear la
reforestación y que sea una manera más
exitosa y eso tiene que ver nuestra
cuarta meta que es que hay más
profesionales para la conservación de
bera que inspirados por enseñar perú
creamos esta campaña que se llama
conserva
con la que le damos becas a jóvenes
profesionales para que hagan pasantías
cursos y puedan viajar también gente de
lima áreas de conservación en las hierba
o en la zona rural para donar su talento
a esas causas
ellas son jóvenes de la comunidad activa
de puerto prado la mayor segunda de la
izquierda es cara y manu llama y es
profesora y con unas de una de estas
vetas lo que se logró es que karen puede
enseñarle a los demás jóvenes niños y
niñas de la comunidad de puerto prado a
aprender la lengua cocama cocamilla que
le estaban perdiendo y así recuperar su
lengua y su identidad ese es un caso en
el que ayudamos a un grupo de
arquitectos y diseñadores que crearon un
proyecto que se llama albergues
naturales y pusieron su talento a
disposición para remodelar por completo
un albergue que está en jaén en
cajamarca donde lucen otro y su familia
protegen el hábitat de especies
endémicas como el fringe y lo pizarra do
en los bosques secos de jaén y la quinta
meta es la de producción y consumo
sostenible porque es lo que les dije
antes es la única forma de cerrar el
círculo de hace 6 años venimos
organizando con nuestras salidas de live
autos
la campaña es la por tu playa que
permite ha permitido que más de 10.000
personas salgan a limpiar las playas por
el perú pero no solamente eso sino que
la limpieza al recoger basura que está
en las playas te genera mayor conciencia
sobre el tipo de productos que consumen
y te puede hacer mucho más consciente a
la hora que definen qué tipo de
productos elegir en el futuro además
hemos creado esta masa crítica de
personas que ahora nos ayudan en las
propuestas de ley que estamos haciendo
al congreso para que se reduzca y se
regule el plástico un solo uso en el
perú y con la información que tenemos
porque ahora sabemos que por ejemplo las
bolsas y las cañitas son los principales
objetos encontramos en las limpiezas de
playas
también sabemos cuáles son las
principales empresas cuyos productos
están en las playas y tenemos la
información para llegar a esas marcas y
plantearles que se comprometan a cambios
para que puedan bajar en los rankings de
cuáles son las empresas que más
encontramos en las empiezas the planets
yo quiero cerrar con una reflexión que a
mí me marcó que fue la de la que leí en
el libro sapiens del historiador un
profesor de oxford que se llama yuval
harary y él plantea que en la sociedad
actual necesitamos para hacer
colaboración en masa necesitamos tener
ciertos mitos ciertas narrativas como lo
fue el sueño americano o como lo fue el
capitalismo lo es hasta ahora más bien
y yo creo que el principal meta de
nuestros tiempos es la regeneración
y hay tres redes personas que quiero
hablar el día de hoy la primera de la
regeneración es la reconciliación en la
forma como nos relacionamos con
naturaleza porque ahorita estamos
basados nuestra relación en naturaleza
en donde es una relación basada en el
aprovechamiento y tenemos que volver a
una visión basada en la reciprocidad la
segunda es la relocalización los
problemas globales son tan grandes que
abruman a cualquiera pero cuando los
realizamos cuando lo hacemos manejables
a nivel local podemos y sentimos el
impacto nuestras acciones y en un mundo
tan conectado por la tecnología la
historia que cuenta el cambio de una
localidad puede amplificar se y lograr
cambios escala global y la tercera tiene
que ver un cambio sistémico más grande y
más complejo que es como sentamos las
bases para la regeneración yo creo que
ahí el reto principal es como hacemos
cuando satisfacemos nuestras necesidades
necesidades de hogar necesidades de
alimentos de vestimenta no solamente
estamos pensando en cómo generamos un
impacto menor sino que la satisfacción
estas necesidades se vuelva una excusa o
una forma para poder
generar algún espacio naturaleza
poniendo esto en concreto cuando
apagamos la luz
deberíamos estar ayudando al padre salud
con un porcentaje que sea para
incentivar el desarrollo las energías
renovables y no los combustibles fósiles
cuando pagamos la cuenta de agua tendría
que haber un porcentaje que es para
mejorar la cuenca de dónde viene esa
agua cuando compramos una fruta o
verdura
tenemos que estar pagando por la
regeneración de los suelos y no la
degradación de los suelos cuando
compramos frutas y verduras que vienen
cargadas de pesticidas y fertilizantes
yo creo que acaba un par de siglos si
nosotros logramos hacer esos cambios y
que la opción por default cuando vayamos
a comprar algo el supermercado sea la
opción que la regenerativa que sea la
opción mainstream no que sea la más cara
que sea la que tienes que buscar en un
lugar diferente vamos a poder ser vistos
acá dos siglos como la generación red no
la generación que rechazó el reto sino
la generación que decidió asumir el reto
y no decidió ser neutral ni indiferente
en un mundo en crisis gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]